meta-information interpretation what is
that for now all of the audio and image
files are being imported with metadata
and it's taking a lot of time for and
most of the time is being spent on
interpreting things like dates to date
objects and quantities into quantity
objects and so forth we would like to be
able to first of all turn that
interpretation off but still be able to
get raw metadata back or be able to
specify our own you know the user it's
his own interpretation function to go
from dates to whatever they want and
things like that just just get me here
just you know get all of it get a data
object time object and so forth mm-hmm
well I think this is a hacky way to do
that if I might say so I mean it's it's
some let me think about that for a
second I mean this is basically it's an
import element right
no it's an import option yeah but meta
information is not an import option
matter information is an import element
element yes right this is trying to
banks which what would otherwise be you
know you're saying there are a bunch of
elements which have you know it's like
in that discussion we just had about
network packet capture there no not that
I'm sorry about you weren't in it it was
about walk files web archive files there
are raw cases in there are non raw cases
and we were distinguishing those by
names given for the import elements so
in this case I mean what will be an
example of something where we import
with meta information get the example
data cornflower jpg in so import import
example data the string one yeah
what am i doing um example data a string
example data / comb flower
that is our case cornflour uppercase
lowercase all cornflour Oh
so there are cornflowers
you sure right think so are you right
and if you ask for options of that I
think that's wrong I think that's a
cornflower yeah I never if I check that
well let's let's make sure it's figure
enough
it's gonna say it's a potato
or something
oh I'm wrong you're right we're all good
yeah isn't it amazing that we can
actually do this and have it work yeah
yeah um okay anyway go ahead you're
saying with this end port now I ask for
options of that image
and see most of the things that are
interpreted quantities exposure time 1
over 65 of the second date times
exposure values look what you're
proposing is a hack why not have this be
lazy if the options somehow if you could
somehow make options of this image
object be lazy then we could solve this
problem
does that make sense
not quite well if I import it into the
notebook so at save time at least it has
to be imported right and then what if
they lazy I don't mean that the the
import hasn't happened I mean the
interpretation hasn't happened if in the
internal form there was a non
interpreted if in the internal form of
image you could have non interpreted
options non interpretive matter
information but when you explicitly ask
for options it goes ahead and interprets
I'm not sure what if I overwrite one of
them by set options well then you have
to deal with that case I mean but but do
you still how would how would we know if
it's something that explicitly a user
had put in and they don't want it to be
really interpreted again or it's
something directly from the file and we
have to interpret it now well I'm saying
that you would have to have I mean this
is an internal implementation thing with
caching and so on I mean this this is
slightly non-trivial but I just don't
think we should expose to the user this
question of the fact that you know this
week these things are a little bit slow
because the fact is I don't even know
why they're slow like some of these
things it might be that we need
interpreter caching some of them are you
know like these dates on they structure
dates are they being imported to
structure dates for image objects for
image files they are for some of the
audio file formats you're looking into
they're not
because that too wild and wooly yes
maybe we need a different structure date
interpreter that covers those kinds of
things I'm simply not convinced about
this I don't think it's right I think I
think we should figure out how to get
the implementation to work rather than
try and hack around it okay but the
other thing that we have done say for
JPEG and TIFF is that we have previous
versions I think 11th one maybe we
introduced exif as well as roy exists
for some of these classes we have raw
versions that one you're fine with still
having so that we can import interpreted
or raw versions if you explicitly want
raw rexif all good okay my objection is
to this thing which is basically you
know I don't even know what it returns
here it returns something with strings
in it which you can't really use strings
or integers or real numbers but I mean
you know there's no harm in saying raw
matter information and returning that
okay what I'm saying is that the default
case should not be switchable like that
it should simply you know just do the
right thing internally okay
in fact we are going to add meta
information as a general option to all
of the file formats or you know we're
gradually going to implement it but
whatever file format that has meta
information we're going to have a
standard meta information element for it
and maybe a raw metal information fine
yeah right for the ones where there's a
um alright orally for run length
encoding the code that we got from Ed is
fairly limited it's no for larger files
it also doesn't support color maps or
Alize okay and a third that would be we
had a little bit of problem with export
but I think we're going to that that's
not going to be a big issue I'm fine
putting the version we have now but we
don't have a whole lot of time you know
writing that cumber therefore 11 3
I just put in what we have and make it
experimental I think okay
have you made any moral formats the
experimental we just we can I think you
just tagged the file yeah okay um I
should run here um okay I'm looking at
the other things here embedded thumbnail
import element you out make sense
oh my gosh bio formats link
we're on Google what are we going to
have those formats in the system no we
had licensing issue with the library
okay GPL okay are we going to have stub
pages for them in any way oh we could I
think right we can just link to the
github repo for all of from all of those
and so I mean long as we can give away
to UM import the things I mean once we
have external object specifications we
could just make those things you know
have some kind of packet download things
that has them work if ever they use
pulling them from github mm-hmm um
alright I think we're gonna need one
more iteration here because we've got to
talk about spectrograms and we've got to
talk a little bit more about the speech
synthesis anyway so we'll need another
iteration so what we should wrap here so
very good all right I'll see you um I
have no idea whether I might even see
you in another meeting today otherwise
have a fine Thanksgiving all right okay
see you bye